[Music]
so jack let me ask you a question about
the
anxiety suffused
society in which we find ourselves and
this is a question i'm i i'm very
interested in personally
so
to what extent do you think about
creating
the
ideal environment for yourself and your
loved ones
versus
adjusting to an anxiety suffused society
that is unlikely
to be wholly changed by your efforts and
it makes me think of a very often quoted
quote of krishnamurti's which is it is
no measure of health to be well adjusted
to a profoundly sick society but one
could argue that that is absolving
yourself of any responsibility so how do
you think about
between those two
or a ratio between those two
or contending with that tension if
they're if you see any tension between
those two i love your question because
it's a little like a zen koan you know
the world is on fire it's in flames do i
stay around and try to put the fire out
or the titanic's going down do i help
people into the in the lifeboats you
know or do i flee do i go in the
mountains or do i get a little lifeboat
and so forth
do i stay or do i go
and the answer to those kind of koans is
yes
you gave the little mathematical answer
how do you titrate it
in some fashion because i think it's
both you know the metaphor that everyone
uses these days is you know put on your
oxygen mask first before you put it on
your children
there's a way in which we have a
responsibility to ourselves
to try to stay healthy and well
and i know you know if i go into a
refugee camp it doesn't help if i go in
and i'm depressed and anxious
they're already feeling that they don't
need me to breathe they actually need
somebody who says yeah this is suffering
and there are ways to manage it there
are ways even though it's difficult
there are ways and there are
possibilities
for us
the great anthropologists and
philosopher wade davis said
despair
is a failure of the imagination
that's a good one it's a brilliant line
because it speaks to the heart despair
is a failure of the imagination
human beings
have been in tough times
since caves and saber-toothed tigers
since you know
battles between different clans
and then we don't have to talk about
the huns and the visigoths or the roman
army or the you know the armies of the
aztecs or wherever around the world we
human beings have dealt with epidemics
blood
tornadoes
continuing war is not a new story right
and we're survivors
and we survive
in two ways first of all we survive by
protecting what we care about which is
ourselves and those close to us so i do
that i want to protect my grandson have
them live in a place where it's safe if
if that's possible or safe enough
or myself
but i also don't want to turn away
for two reasons
my daughter said well if climate change
and everything gets battery you know
would you move to new zealand or would
you you know would you get and i said
you know i
i choose to be on the
deck of the titanic and i'll help people
in the lifeboats that's just
that's what i've
taken as a vow as a bodhisattva that you
turn towards suffering and you offer
what you can
but part of that offering
is to see that the world that i want for
my grandson
needs my attending
and it doesn't mean i can change it
because this is the way the world in
some ways but it can be better or it can
be worse and we know that we can stand
up for things that really matter
and so your question which is a really
it's a question of the heart it's also
different for different people there's
some people who are profoundly
contemplative and i think the extreme
are those tibetan yogis in the cave who
are broadcasting compassion to everybody
in the world
if we're all connected as they say as
we find
then that's their contribution
but then there i was out on the streets
in march for your lives in dc for this
and that was also important
and i love the fact it was not this one
but with the prior march for your lives
i forget who it was but there was a
fantastic you know
black gospel singer who stood up
and she sang
in a sort of gospel style bob dylan's
the times they are a change in
you know 40 years after it came out
um gather around people that times are
changing don't block up the wall and i
listened and it was it was the very same
medicine that we needed and i felt so
glad to be out there with people and i
felt so glad that
we were doing lobbying petitions and
sending money and trying to support the
organizations and do what we could
and i've also worked with kids coming
out of street gangs in the cities
and they're
they're veterans too when we've had
retreats with
army veterans
military veterans coming back combat
veterans and some of these young kids
they look at each other
in their eyes and they nod and they know
that they've all been together in battle
because some of these kids have seen as
much shooting as some of these events
have
and so we actually need to tend to that
and it becomes part of our
i don't know our uh
any part of our life purpose
in some way yes to take care of yourself
but yourself isn't separate
to take care of yourself is everything
you